[Musique]
pendant une longue période j'ai
travaillé comme entrepreneur et puis
pour les entreprises et puis depuis
maintenant 20 ans je travaille pour les
territoires les collectivités
territoriales je les aide dans le
développement l'attractivité
c'est sans doute je pense à cause de ces
deux expériences que j'ai eu un rêve
j'ai imaginé que l'altruisme alors la
truie vous savez c'est au faut s'occuper
des autres de façon désintéressée
sans chercher de contrepartie de contre
eux voilà la tiu mal compris donc c'est
la philanthropie
c'est la charité c'est le don fait tout
ça alors imaginez que l'altruisme
permettent de développer du business
imaginez que le don permettent de rendre
les territoires les entreprises plus
compétitif
imaginez le monde entier en train de se
mobiliser vers l'altruisme parce que ça
crée du business pur et dur vous
imaginez ça mais ça serait dingue tout
le monde irait trump poutine ou faire
n'importe qui tout le monde irait parce
que ça crée du business alors c'est vrai
que si je le dis comme ça ça paraît très
utopique vous propose de rentrer dans
mon utopie réaliste parce que je crois
qu'elle est très réaliste
alors d'abord il ya une bonne nouvelle
vous avez derrière le fondation
on est en france et les fondations c'est
plus 78%
comme il ya deux fondations en europe
148 1148 1148 mille la croissance
permanente le don se développe en
permanence mais pourquoi le don se
développe pourquoi aujourd'hui dans nos
sociétés le don se développe c'est à
cause de l'économie qui va mieux oui un
peu quand elle allait moins bien ça se
développe et moi ça a même baissé un
petit peu aux états unis
c'est à cause d'eux des lois la loi tepa
10 2002 2007 la défiscalisation oui un
peu ça joue un peu c'est à cause de bill
et melinda gates
souvenez-vous warren buffett qui lance
le giving pledge et qui disent les très
riches au monde doivent donner la moitié
de leur fortune
il ya 170 ultra riches qui donne et on
voit l'investissement sur la santé
notamment en afrique qui fait un bond
alors oui ça a joué mais enfin par
rapport au niveau mondial c'est une
explication partielle
est ce que c'est le numérique qui permet
du financement participatif dont une
partie est désintéressé est-ce que c'est
tout ça est ce que c'est la génération
des millenium ce qui est en train
d'arriver et qui donne beaucoup plus que
ma génération et ils sont en train
d'exploser dans les chiffres parce que
il considère que donner c'est naturel
c'est ça la raison pour lesquelles le
dong mans c'est pas ça la raison
ça joue bien sur la vraie raison c'est
parce que ça crée du sov wiston
churchill il disait nous gagnons notre
vie avec ce que nous recevons mais nous
donnons du sens à notre vie est ce que
nous donnons mais vous - à tous
lorsqu'on donne bien sûr que c'est du
sens bien entendu que c'est du sens
c'est être même un peu plus que du sort
ce une sorte de couteau suisse très
performant quand on part du don qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec du don on donne une
vision quand on est dans une entreprise
et qu'on donne la vision quand on donne
le sens qu'est ce qui se passe
l'immédiatement immédiatement libère les
énergies légende se mobilisent le sens
et de la mobilisation
et puis ça fédère quand on se met tout
sur une cause commune pour un bien
commun qu'on fait quelque chose
souvenez vous quand vous l'avez fait on
est tous fédérés là il ya plus vache on
est tous ensemble mais il n'ya pas que
ça le don si j'interroge un expert de
marketing le sens il n'y a pas de sens
c'est ce qui fait acheter ah bon le sang
c'est ce qui fait acheter
oui si j'achète un yacht et qu'en plus
on me propose de faire quelque chose de
bien qui me valorise qui dit à mon
entourage je suis un type bien parce que
je fais ça en plus et je reverse temps
où je fais ça est-ce que ça fait acheter
oui ça fait acheter toutes les études le
monde vision mobiliser et fédérer
achetez vous imaginez n'y a pas que ça
est-ce que ça lève des fonds
savez vous mesdames et messieurs combien
il ya deux d'argent disponible en cash
à l'instant où je parle dans les
fondations américaines européennes je
parle même pas de l'asie combien 1600
milliards 1600 milliards à l'instant où
je vous parle sont disponibles en cash
si ça ça fait pas lever des fonds mais
alors je regarde tout ça je me dis mais
c'est extraordinaire
le don le sens il fait tout ça mais quel
est le problème des entreprises
aujourd'hui mobilisée donner une vision
fédérer aider à vendre et les problèmes
des territoires et les élus expliqué je
travaille depuis vingt ans quel est le
problème qu'ils ont n'y a pas de vision
on n'arrive pas à mobiliser les acteurs
essaient des fonctionnaires parfois qui
font les stratégies et les acteurs du
territoire sont pas mobilisés c'est ça
le problème des territoires et vous
mêmes citoyens souvenez vous de votre
attitude
il n'y a pas de sens vous voulez du sens
mais consommateurs veulent du sang les
salariés veulent du sang tout le monde
veut ça mais alors pourquoi les
entreprises n'utilisent pas puisque ça
fait tout ça pourquoi les territoires ne
s'adresse pas à l'altruisme pour trouver
le cash qu'ils n'ont plus il ya plus
d'argent dans les collectivités
on n'arrive pas à financer on a toute la
télévision toute la journée qui nous dit
les hôpitaux les restos n'ont pas assez
l'explosion il n'y a pas d'argent
pourquoi on n'utilise pas pour créer de
la valeur à le mot est lâché mais parce
que vous et moi
quand on vous dit altruiste dont charité
vous dites c'est une valeur humaine mais
c'est pas de la valeur économique
c'est quoi la valeur économique mais
moins chef d'entreprise je diminue en un
truisme c'est bien on va peut-être sur
une opération pour souder le personnel
mais on va
clé de la valeur et que ça il ya un
grand gourou américain michael porter il
s'appelle qui lui a travaillé sur la
chaîne de valeur y dit si vous voulez
dans un territoire par exemple créé
d'avalleur vous rassemblez entreprise
vous mettez de l'innovation et de créer
ce qu'on appelle des clusters ou des
pôles de compétitivité si vous voulez ça
c'est créer de la valeur et dans une
entreprise que les ballons on sait ce
que c'est faire un prix plus bas
il a dit ça c'est créer de la valeur
faire une innovation à nouveau service
on crée de la valeur mais l'altruisme
sacré de laveur mais mon pauvre
l'altruisme sera jamais un avantage
compétitif
comment voulez vous qu'un touriste a un
avantage compétitif jamais il ne sera
bien moins je pense qu'ils se trompent
l'altruisme c'est non seulement de la
création de valeur c'est un avantage
compétitif
je sens bien que vous avez des doutes et
bien je vous propose de partir avec moi
dans un petit voyage je suis à londres
je suis à new york à paris et je veux
partir en week-end comme on dit un
week-end romantique avec ma femme
alors je pars en ricanant d'antiques
parce que on s'est engueulé parce que
j'ai des trucs à me faire pardonner
enfin peu importe la région
je pars ce qui est sûr c'est que on veut
partir en week-end en main tic et donc
qu'est ce que je fais je fais comme vous
je vais sur internet je vois des hôtels
je sélectionne je sais que la carte
bleue va chauffer parce que j'ai
beaucoup de trucs à me faire pardonner
donc je prends des hôtels un peu luxueux
là j'en ai trouvé de juste à côté là
parce qu'évidemment la provence on est
en provence est formidable pour partir
donc je vais là à l'isle sur la sorgue
vous savez ce village avec les
antiquaires des roues et tout ça est
donc je vais là pour mon week-end je
suis devant mes deux hôtels je regarde
mes hommes psg regarder dedans et dit
tiens il ya un truc curieux alors
j'appuie je me dis mais c'est quoi ce
petit macaron qui est à gauche et là
tout d'un coup il ya un truc je passe la
souris dessus un truc qui s'ouvre est là
il ya écrit quoi nous sommes fiers
d'avoir rejoint le club entreprises
positive des partenaires de la fondation
de l'isle sur la sorgue
en mettant en oeuvre une démarche
citoyenne et durable du développement de
territoire c'est l'hôtelier qui me parle
et en construisant un touriste positif
qui favorise l'altruisme et la rencontre
entre les visiteurs et les habitants
nous participons à la réussite d'un
trêve collectif de construire de faire
de notre ville le modèle de la ville
idéale de demain waouh
alors je crois pas que c'est ça qui va
me faire forcément acheter enfin je me
dis qu'ils dans cette ville eux en plus
moi je suis touriste je veux aller là
bas on ne promet de rencontrer des
habitants de partager et c'est rare je
les vois c'est sympa appuyé cette ville
duras positif
sympa belle image voilà mais bon ça me
change pas mon élément du tiens c'est
marrant ils sont tous engagés dans cet
élément et je dis bon alors il faut que
je sélectionne ma chambre
alors qu'est ce que je fais je regarde
ma chambre je fais comme vous je vais
dessus puis se dit voilà 540 euros à wil
carte bleue va chauffer pour deux jours
effectivement c'est pas donné mais enfin
bon
encore une fois je vais régler quelques
problèmes donc ça va être impeccable
confirmer ma réserve
qu'est ce que je fais se confirme et là
on me dit on vous remercie d'avoir
préservé et puis une nouvelle fenêtre
qui s'ouvre là il ya écrit quoi
entreprises positive
nous sommes heureux grâce à vous
s'adresse à moi je suis devant mon écran
grâce à vous nous sommes heureux de
reverser 3 euros pour soutenir des
projets touristiques innovants et
d'intérêt général dit nous vous voulez
dans ces trois projets qui sont là en
dessous que votre argent aille alors je
regarde ces trois projets on me propose
quoi vous rendez compte je venais de
réserver sa 140 euros j'ai fait mon
virement d'argent et où d'un combi
letellier je prends trois euros et je
finance et où vous voulez vous on me
demande mon avis à moi
abel gym et 3 euros attendait puisque
vous prenez mes 3 euros on me propose de
fournir de l'électricité pour les roues
ils vont branché de l'électricité sur
les roues profondeur gratuitement de
l'électricité ça c'est le premier show
propose de mettre internet gratuit ce
qu'on appelle le l'ifi vous savez c'est
les ampoules toutes les ampoules de la
ville fournissent gratuitement de
l'internet où poussaient dans la ville
vous le payez pas y est gratuit ça passe
par l'électricité formidable
truc très innovant ou troisième solution
il ya un petit train touristique
électrique moi je suis tories je viens
dans cette ville on aurait pu bien pour
soutenir des projets touristiques qui
améliore votre séjour ou qu'ils
amélioreront demain je me dis c'est
super sympa mais moins mais 3 euros je
voudrais qu'ils aillent à la roue
électrique
moi je voudrais ça je trouve ça
vachement sympa de faire de
l'électricité gratuitement et cléroux
qui tournait l'eau ok moi je voudrais
que mes oreilles là mais 3 euros alors
je clique dessus oui et au moment je
clique
merci d'avoir soutenir ce projet on dit
dit oui si vous voulez suivre ce projet
l'avancement dans le temps on tiendra
compte qui sera financé grâce à vous
entre autres qu'est ce que je fais je me
dis c'est sympa je fais oui évidemment
probablement peut-être propre et oui
qu'est ce que je viens de faire là je
suis venu dans un territoire et j'ai
effectivement voulu réserver et là
l'image que j'ai de ce territoire
l'instant où je vous parle je suis
toujours devant mon ordinateur à paris à
londres ou ailleurs
quelle image est je me dis d'abord c'est
des gens l'isle sur la sorgue citoyens
durable touriste positif on appelle ça
l'économie positive savez celle qui la
transmission la durabilité et
l'altruisme précisément ça s'appelle
l'économie positif de 10 saisons là ils
font un truc formidable deuxième élément
pour moi lit sur la sorgue c'était un
village très traditionnel tourisme et
tout d'un coup il me propose de financer
que des trucs innovants
mon image des lycées à saint pons fait
la changer un petit peu qui tient il
finance des trucs qui n'avance un
laboratoire ce truc là ils sont très en
pointe ces gens là alors que j'avais
l'image de choses classiques et puis
troisièmement ils viennent de lever des
fonds concrètement imaginer tous les
hôtels face à tous les restaurants ça ça
roule à ça va lever beaucoup d'argent
c'est exactement
et l'hôtelier lui valent hôtelier lui
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait déjà moins
l'hôtelier je me dis ce type leape rang
mais 3 euros il reverse et tout altruy
sympa c'est un hôtel positif c'est quand
même sympa autre chose l'image que j'en
ai d'innovation c'est pareil ça
rejaillit sur l'hôtelier
mois le client je me dis cet hôtelier il
est sympa en plus il m'a proposé une
expérience les gens de marketing parle
d'expérience yale je viens de vivre une
expérience j'avais cru payer 547 est
fini tout d'un coup on propose d'aider
des gens de faire un truc bien avec mes
540 euros tout d'un coup qui était juste
mon week-end pour me réconcilier hop
tout d'un coup je fais un truc bien
évidemment que l'hôtelier est valorisée
et en plus il propose une autre enfin
dit quand vous viendrez vous allez
rencontrer des habitants quand vous
partez quelque part et vous allez chez
des copains qu'est ce que vous leur
dites m'amène pas dans un truc
touristique moi je veux aller dans les
restos où les gens du coin c'est ça
qu'on me propose donc ça effectivement
c'est très positif
et puis enfin il m'a proposé un lien ou
là là mais ça c'est de l'or les gens de
marketing dit c'est quoi l'avenir
l'avenir c'est un lien personnalisé
entre un client et une marque entre un
territoire entre un hôtelier
or qu'est ce que je viens faire à votre
avis quand je vais arriver dans l'hôtel
de quoi je vais parler à la réception et
oui je vais arriver je vais dire bon
alors la roue elle en est où là le
financement parce que mes 3 euros
évidemment je vais parler ça je viens de
créer un lien entre un hôtelier mois on
parle pas de business là on parle
d'autre chose vous rendez compte d'une
valeur mais c'est dingue je suis parti
de 3 euros vous savez combien ça fait
sur 540 0 6% 0 6%
je viens de créer des valeurs dans tous
les coins pour le territoire pour
l'hôtelier a évidemment pour moi et on
va terminer là dessus évidemment moins
c'est énorme
j'ai mis du sens dans mon achat j'avais
540 euros tout d'un coup je fais un truc
bien en plus on met reconnaissant
souvenez-vous ce qu'on m'a dit dans le
texte
grâce à vous merci monsieur grâce à vous
on finance des choses formidables truc
génial
et en plus on m'a proposé de
l'expérience évidemment là aussi et on
m'a laissé le choix à aucun moment sud
contraintes tout ça c'est la création de
valeur pour un b contre j'ai changé
l'image d'un territoire
j'ai créé de la valeur j'ai un avantage
concurrentiel
est-ce que les hôtels d'aix me propose
ça non
c'est donc un avantage concurrence
je viens de vous démontrer que
l'altruisme peut faire créer des
avantages concurrentiels et si on était
complètement fou on continuera en se
disant et pourquoi on ne fait pas tout
le monde
et pourquoi on fait pas quand on achète
j'arrive aller à lille sur un seul jeu
rentiers un commerce pourquoi il ne
propose pas de renverser 0,50 centimes 1
euro ça c'est ce que fait l'hôtel de
caumont à aix en provence mais l'hôtel
quand redon à lille peut faire la même
chose et pour qu'on me propose ça et
pourquoi pas tous les commerces
proposerait des cas mais vous non non je
veux quand même pas je suis pas du tout
cas je veux tous les commerces pas je
vais aller voir tous les commerçants je
vais leur dire vous le faites vous allez
voir comment ça va vous rapporter et je
vais leur faire un montage comme on
vient de le voir sur l'hôtelier regarder
ce que vous allez avoir et je peux
continuer et si je mettais tout les
arrondis vous savez si l'entreprise qui
propose de donner l'arrondi par exemple
votre feuille de paye
dans notre pays on vous dit voilà vous
gagnez 2542 se voit 6,57 est-ce que vous
acceptez tous les mois que le sentiment
là vous le métier dans la fondation
qu'on soutient et avec mes fournisseurs
je leur dis voilà il ya des factures je
suis prêt à vous payer votre facture
mais je vois que vous acceptiez de les
sentiments vous le verser à la fondation
le seul fournisseur et je le fais avec
mes clients la même chose et imaginant
je fasse avec le boulanger je vais dans
la boulangerie jeu du monsieur boulanger
vous le faites bien avec les pièces
jaunes chaque année et pourquoi vous
feriez pas toute l'année on vous met une
boîte parce que là il n'ya pas
l'ordinateur et pourquoi généralise a
relevé bancaire tient les banquiers ça
tombe bien cela et pourquoi je leur dis
pas vos relevés bancaires l'arrondi
bancaire pour qu'on leur verse pas où
vous vous prenez une quote part et
pourquoi je trouve pas des banquiers
qu'ils acceptent de faire ce que lui a
accepté de faire ce banquier là qu'est
ce qu'il a fait avec l'auvergne tt
ouvert nouveau monde une carte de
paiement
chaque transaction des abbés commerce
n'apportent ou 3 centimes partait
directement pour financer le
développement en l'occurrence des écoles
qu'est ce qui empêche les banques de
faire ça rien rien du tout et si j'ai ma
fondation entreprises positive qui est
là au milieu celle qu'on a créés et si
je dis aux banquiers chaque fois vous le
faites ça va valoriser
merci pour la fondation banque positive
parce qu'ils en ont besoin ça va être
génial c'est la folie ce que je suis en
train de faire
je suis en train de transformer toute
l'économie de l'isle sur la sorgue vous
imaginez toute l'économie
allez on n'en prend que 20% qu'accepte
j'ai un rêve fou s'est trouvé un
territoire car celle de faire ça un qui
dit aller chez pilote le fait eh bien
ils viennent de démarrer ce territoire
c'est à l'isle sur la sorgue juste à
côté
ils sont partis là-dessus en acceptant
de transformer de fer l'altruisme trans
basculer toute l'économie dans ce qu'on
appelle l'économie positive mais vous
vous êtes dans cette salle vous allez
voir vos territoires vous allez voir vos
élus vous allez voir vos entreprises et
vous leur dites fait ça on va créer du
business je vais vous démontrer que
l'entreprise est plus rentable
c'est un rêve fou mais vous allez faire
avec moi et si on refuse que vous le
fassiez alors venez nous aider on fera
lille je vous remercie de votre
attention très positive
[Applaudissements]